That is she, the one who can save our queen?
More, She will save our world.
So much for taking a night off.
Welcome back everyone, Happy holidays!
This will be my full Marvel
What If Season 2 Episode 5 Video
There were a whole bunch of Easter Eggs and references
so we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes.
Big reminder that they're airing once per day.
So like we've started to get post-credits
scenes and teasers for what the finale is going to be.
We're actually going to see that finale
literally in a couple of days.
careful for spoilers.
If you haven't seen the episode yet, we'll just start
at the beginning, work our way through shop.
I shall I talk about Easter eggs?
WTF moments starting with the episode title.
What if Captain Carter fought the Hydra Stomper,
which is basically like the sequel
to the Captain Carter episodes from season
one in that post-credits scene from season one.
during the opening scene, Captain Carter's
Battle of New York happens
during her events of the first Avengers
movie, with history being slightly
different based on what happened
previously in season one.
instead of getting stuck in the ice,
she was transported to present day
with the Tesseract portal during the events
of that Avengers movie instead of Loki arriving in.
That's how she wound up on that present day
Avengers team.
But then the watcher showed up
to take her to the Multiverse Avengers team.
But as he explains, after the events of Season one,
he returned
everybody to where he took them
from in the exact moment.
and because he joined her from that present day
Avengers period, he took her back to that and they just
pick up with the events of that first Avengers movie
being slightly different in this reality.
Her Avengers team during that first Avengers
movie is Captain Carter, obviously leading the team.
It is Hayley Atwell doing The Voice again,
Black Widow, played by Lake Bell again.
She plays Black Widow in all the episodes
and she played black Widow in season one.
Jeremy Renner came back as a version of Hawkeye
Iron Man is here, Thor in the WASP.
Instead of the Hulk being on the team.
but there is a Bruce Banner
Hulk that exists in this universe.
They referenced him later in the episode.
pretty much everybody suits looks similar
to the ones they wore during the first Avengers movie
or like in Captain Carter's
case, it's based on Captain America during that movie.
Based on her original suit.
So it's like a more modernized version of her
Captain Britain looking suit.
the wasp suit
looks like the one that she was wearing in Ant-Man
and the WASP, just like a red version of that.
The wasp Being on the team is also a bit of a reference
to the original Avengers team.
When The Avengers first formed in the 1960s, WASP
was a big part of that original roster, fun fact too.
When they were making the first live action
MCU Avengers movie, they actually almost
put a version of WASP on the team played by Zoe
de Chanel.
Can you believe what that would have been like
if she had played a version of the WASP?
so. I think that's why they put her
on this version of the team.
Like it's is a bit of a meta Easter egg,
like this alternate version of a live action
MCU Avengers that almost wound up happening.
nice little trek I picked up in Berlin.
I want eyes in the sky.
Iron Man. Thor, keep the fighting down.
The all their witty banter the dialog is similar
to the banter in the first Avengers movie.
They take down the Qatari
captain Carter Black Widow Stop Loki Having a Punchable
face is meant to be a reference
to Hawke thrashing him in the live action MCU version.
we get a brief cameo from the Watcher
inside his multiverse base.
It's located between universes depicting them
as facets of a mirror like him, just watching different
television stations, basically,
they're shards into realities floating around him.
Black Widow, Iron Man scene,
all random scenes from previous episodes.
In future episodes.
Some of them seem like season one, Episodes two
I don't do sequels normally?
He breaks the fourth wall when he says
he doesn't do sequels, meaning that he knows he's
a fictional character inside a TV show
that has episodes.
The Watchers done this in previous
comic books before, like Broken the Fourth Wall,
but typically there are very few comic book
characters in Marvel that break the fourth wall.
Like Deadpool, she hoped, for instance, She-Hulk
did the exact same thing
during the live action MCU, but she actually broke
the fifth wall when she was doing that.
And that's usually when you address
the writers of the show.
Like she literally paused her show in, backed out
on Disney, Plus like she left her show literally
one of the other shows that does stuff like this
all the time is Rick and Morty.
Like Rick always references that.
He knows he's a fictional character inside a TV show,
and sometimes he's broken the fifth wall.
Addressing the writers of the show directly
The Watchers Fourth Wall Break
is also a call back to the original.
What if comic books each different
What if comic book is meant to be
a completely different story
with an alternate history in some major event?
but the whole idea here is they brought Captain Carter
back from season one just because the showrunners
really liked the character so much
and they wanted to continue that serialized aspect that
they had during season one with some of the characters
coming back to form the Multiverse Avengers team.
This time
she's actually coming back for the same reason
to like another multiverse Avengers team, but
it's being put together by Scarlet Witch, who we see
at the end of the episode in a bit of an end credit
tag scene in Nick Fury in a marvel 1602 adaptation.
you probably picked up on this too.
But Elizabeth Olsen and Samuel Jackson
both came back to voice their characters.
so this is technically the first time
that Elizabeth Olsen has come back as Scarlet Witch
after Doctor Strange Multiverse of Madness,
even though it's like a completely different version
of the character.
more? She will save our world.
I know there's all kinds of questions, too, like, isn't
the Scarlet Witch supposed to be singular?
Like this only meant to be one Scarlet Witch
for the entire multiverse.
And like all the other versions of Wanda,
never become scarlet witches in their own universes.
There's always been a couple of moments like that
in the
what if television show where they're like,
small details that are a little inconsistent.
you can get really into the weeds on the logic
behind that, but I wouldn't go too crazy about it.
Samuel Jackson
also did the voice of his character in present day
two in all of the other episodes that he appears in.
he shows a couple of scenes from the ending of season
one with that multiverse of interesting,
the Guardians of the Multiverse,
The reason why he pauses on Supreme Strange
is because we'll also get Supreme Strange
coming back at the end of the episodes
for the Marvel 1602 episodes,
there's a bit of a time jump
and they do their version of Captain America
Winter Soldier with the Captain Carter characters.
This time it's Black Widow doing the on your left meme
running around the Washington Monument in Peggy Carter
is the one that's driving the Corvette
coming to pick her up
during the scene, they also flipped the dialog
from the Winter Soldier movie.
So like Captain Carter gets all a Black widow's
MCU dialog
from the Winter Soldier movie,
making jokes about Black Widow.
Hey, lovely.
Need a lift?
You know, you could join me one of these mornings.
Running in circles is never been my style.
she gets her version of the Captain America Civil Suit.
They go on a similar mission on the boat
at the beginning of that movie.
Only this time the Pirates were after the Hydra
Stomper, her skinny boy, Steve
Rogers, who's become this universe's
version of the Winter Soldier.
in his armor has become a more modernized
Russian themed version of what it used to be like.
He's got the red star of Russia on it.
They explain his backstory,
and Bucky's went a little bit differently
because of how they ended World
War Two in their universe.
So after Captain Carter was pulled into her portal
at the end of her episode,
Steve Rogers uses his Hydra Stomper armor suit
and Bucky to go around destroying all the different
Hydra bases all over the world implying that in present
day Hydra doesn't exist anymore.
Like they perma killed Hydra back in the 1940s
in the early 1950s during his last mission.
Like as the Cold War starts to ramp up,
he disappears in their final mission
but turns out he's captured by the black widows
in the red room.
essentially Drake starts to condition him as another
one of the black widows as part of the program.
Buggy survived that last fight in 1953
and just goes back to the U.S., goes into politics,
eventually becoming secretary of state, basically
getting General Thunderbolt Ross's job in the MCU,
exact same job.
It also looks like he becomes the director of the World
Security Council, like Alexander Pierce
was in Winter Soldier because he gets a lot of scenes
that Alexander Pierce had in the Winter Soldier movie.
But because Hydra doesn't exist, he's
not evil in this universe.
I guess just normal Bucky,
But as far as they explain, there's like no secret
Hydra plot going on in the episode.
This is all the red room in the Black Widow's behind it
and if it wasn't clear, even in the MCU
when Hydra still was a thing in present day,
the Red Room was not connected
to Hydra
like they were completely separate organizations.
Black Widow explains.
The Budapest operation with Hawkeye in her universe
goes down pretty much the same way
she thinks she killed Dreykov,
but could never find the location of the Red Room.
He's meant to be dead, but in reality, Melina,
also from the Black Widow movie, takes control
The Red Room and perfects her control technology
in her programs for brainwashing the black widows
in essentially under her, the black widows become
even more effective, more deadly.
Their aerial red room base becomes even better.
Explaining why Natasha never found it
because it was in the sky cloaked all this time.
Rachel Weisz also came back from the Black Widow movie
to voice her character again.
But no Red Guardian and no Yelena Belova.
was proud of you.
You were a very successful killing machine.
But then you became an Avenger.
She fights Betrothed the Leaper
the same way Cat did in the Winter Soldier movie.
They find her Steve Rogers,
who breaks out of his ship in containment,
basically picking up where the season one post-credits
scene left off originally.
I think this episode was actually meant to be episode
one for season two,
but then everything completely changed.
They deleted a couple of times and then changed the way
they actually released the episodes.
Black Widow makes a RoboCop reference,
which Captain Carter has not seen yet,
even though she has seen Star Wars.
Don't worry, we'll get to that.
They have a brief fight, then he escapes.
But as they explain, this is all part of Melina's
plan to lure out Captain Carter.
So she can actually get control over,
which is meant to be another version of the plot
during the Black Widow movie.
That was what Dreykov was trying to do
with Black Widow.
reprogram her so he could have control of someone
inside the Avengers.
And that's what Melina wants.
Like she wants to control Captain Carter inside her
Avenger so she can essentially control the Avengers.
sunlight, the whole first half of the episode.
Skinny Boy Steve Rogers
programing is so good that he's able to fool
Captain Carter and Black Widow
into believing that they successfully saved him.
Everything he does is just a fake
to lure her into a trap.
They explain the main reason why he stayed young.
This time, because he doesn't have the super soldier
serum is because the Hydra Stomper armor
and the new arc reactor that Howard Stark created for
it are slowing his aging process.
But if he takes the armor off,
that's it. Like he'll die.
so essentially he's been wearing that armor
this entire time.
But I assume that they actually put him in cryo storage
Winter soldier style between different missions.
So like it's not like he's been walking around
all this time for years and years and years.
they can also probably open the armor to clean him off.
Otherwise he's going to get super gamey, like, wow,
you stink under that armor
when they go back to Nick Fury,
she has pretty much the same argument with him.
The Captain America had with his Nick Fury in the MCU
about lying to him about what was really going on
and Black Widow lying to him as well, to
they knew the whole time.
The skinny boy, Steve Rogers, was probably still alive
and under the control of the Red Room.
they confirmed that Bigfoot exists in this universe.
But the closest thing to Bigfoot in the actual
Marvel universe is
Walter Sampson from the X-Men comics
who goes by the codename Sasquatch.
But there's no actual Bigfoot in the Marvel Universe.
And I just made that Rick and Morty reference.
They literally
also just did a Bigfoot plot on Rick and Morty.
Nick Fury makes a reference to a shield
not stopping skinny boy Steve Rogers.
That's meant to be a reference to the ending
where she does
finally win him over by putting down the shield
like she does it
without the shield they give Bucky
all of his Alexander Pierce scenes from Winter Soldier.
But like I said, he's not evil.
They brought back Councilman Singh from the Winter
Soldier movie.
Bernard White, who played the character in the movie,
also came back to do The Voice again.
The alien old man Bucky has shared beers
with is Thor, obviously drinks a lot of beer in it.
Sebastian Stan doing the voice again.
He came back to do all the Bucky scenes
in all the different episodes Coby,
an aid package that they're talking about,
implies that the events of Avengers
Age of Ultron will go down differently
in this universe, or maybe never happen at all.
If Ultron is ultimately never created.
it's also meant to set up the ending in Sokovia
in that Russian training town.
He also makes a civil War reference, which is a bit
of a callback to Captain America Civil War.
But in this universe, Sokovia is also literally
in the middle of an actual civil war.
crossbones comes back and it is Frank Grillo
coming back to do the voice again.
But in this universe, remember, Hydra
doesn't exist in present day, so he never joined Hydra,
so he's just like a totally normal, good agent.
in Remember when Steve Rogers
Hydra Stomper attacks Bucky?
He's only attacking Bucky just to lure out
Captain Carter.
Is all meant to be a trap to lure her out
When he makes the plutonium.
And Paul made a joke.
That's just a reference to Howard Stark, eventually
creating a working arc reactor based on the Tesseract.
Because the original Hydra stomper armor was powered
by the tesseract, not an arc reactor then Bucky saved.
Steve Rogers.
Life is also meant to be a reference
like a mirror to Steve Rogers, Captain America
doing the same thing in the Winter Soldier movie.
Like going against orders
because he was trying to save Winter Soldier
black widow takes them to one of her secret hideouts
in St Kilda, Scotland, on this island.
It might be a reference then going to Scotland
during Avengers Infinity War,
but they were in a different town during that movie.
She pours them a vodka,
making a Russian drinking cheer,
also foreshadowing the Black Widow movie storyline
with Melina in the other black widows.
Coming later.
she also suggests using Iron Man in his stark
tech to devise a way to get Steve Rogers
out of his suit.
may be Bruce Banner using his gamma experiments
in serums to keep Steve Rogers
alive, implying that they might turn him into like
a version of the Steve Rogers Hulk to keep him alive.
Captain Carter, unfortunately, says no.
Like, no, we don't need another version of the Hulk
literally just did that during episode three
during the What If Happy Hogan's Save
Christmas episode, where he takes some of the Hawks
gamma serum and becomes a purple version of the Hulk,
when she says, unplugging it and plugging it back in.
That's just a reference
to people's routers in real life.
Like if your Internet is slow or it's not working,
unplug it, then try plugging it back in.
You're in and it'll probably be fine.
Captain Carter then makes a Star Wars
Empire Strikes Back reference, saying that
he'll get stuck in prison, frozen in Carbonite,
revealing that she has seen the Star Wars movies.
Black Widow makes a joke about her being a super nerd.
Like, so that's what you're doing on the weekends.
watching Star Wars movies?
Black Widow also made a similar type of joke
during the Captain America,
the Winter Soldier movie about Steve Rogers
being kind of nerdy, not doing really fun stuff
on the weekends, even though in reality
watching Star Wars movies is actually a lot of fun.
Captain Carter is the one who decides to try
and track down the red room and look for answers there.
Josh Keaton then voices Steve Rogers again, like
he gets his first actual speaking lines in the episode.
He's the voice of spectacular Spider-Man
that most people remember,
who is now Kiernan to the Spider-Man
across the Spider-Verse movies.
technically, that also makes him canon to the MCU, too,
because they crossed over MCU moments in that movie.
they reveal Molina's new Black Widow training
facility is inside Sokovia like
it used to be a Russian facility that the military ran
in the black widows just took it over.
a lot of.
You've also probably picked up on the vibes here.
It's basically meant to be kind of
like a version of Westview from the Wandavision series,
like a quintessential mid-century town gazebo
and all in.
The funny thing about this is this actually
based on real life like during the Cold War,
people in other countries like Russia, for example,
would create towns like this to train their troops.
they make a John Cougar Mellencamp
reference and Captain Carter reveals that Hawkeye
taught her all about Dad Rock.
she also references the multiverse creature
that she fought getting sucked into the portal
during season one.
Then basically they imply here that the Hydra stomper
Steve Rogers is stalling for time
so Molina can arrive with the black widows
in their aerial red room base
They play Captain America in Peggy Carter's
theme music.
Again, it's the same music
they played at the end of Avengers Endgame
when they reunited like at the very end of the movie.
It was meant to be the same song
that was playing for the two of them
during the original Captain America First Avenger movie
they get attacked by all the Black Widow
training dummy shooting the widow stingers at them.
And Captain Carter smokes.
So many of these like it's
an ocean of widow stingers before she goes down, there
their couple of minor changes that they make to history
in this episode two with the Red Room
just in general,
black Widow claims that she grew up on the air base.
But in the MCU, Dreykov didn't create that until 2008,
right after the Budapest operation
where she tried and failed to kill him.
but I think in the context of this universe, the aerial
base, which is created much earlier in the timeline.
Melina returns.
And like I said, it is Rachel
Weisz is coming back to voice the character again in
They brought back
all the black widows from the Black Widow movie.
Like,
these are all the same basic people in this reality.
She's meant to have taken over the Red Room
after Dreykov was killed by Natasha,
and she's wearing an upgraded Black Widow power suit
that gives her way more enhanced
strength, speed, Durability,
Let's just get those crazy, wicked looking heels.
I explain her grand plan here.
Like, her whole gambit was to gain control
of Captain Carter, conditioned her
so that she has somebody inside the Avengers
who she could control and thus control the Avengers.
That's basically the plot of the Black Widow movie.
That was what Dreykov was trying to do with Natasha.
Like get her under his control to get reprogram her
so he could control the Avengers.
Ultimately, basically the rest of the episode plays out
like the end of the Black Widow movie
Captain Carter winds up winning Bucky over
by laying his shield down, breaking his programing
briefly long enough for him to sacrifice himself
kamikaze, destroying the red room
like they destroyed it at the end of the Black Widow
movie with it Crash into the ground.
is implied that Melina was killed
when Black Widow attaches her to his last right there.
But at the end of the episode, Captain Carter
also reveals probably survived that final explosion.
He's just out there somewhere, which is also a callback
to the end of the Winter Soldier movie in
Captain America Civil War, where Cap was still looking
for Bucky, who was alive out there in the wild.
this is meant to be the end of the Black Widow program
in the red room in this universe.
So it's implied that either they'll track down
these of the black widows and help deprogram
or some of them probably became mercenaries
working for other operations around the world.
we get the watcher in the background
watching everything go down during the ending.
Then Captain Carter, after a time jump, steals
one of Iron Man's cars
inside their version of the Avengers tower, claiming
that Steve Rogers still alive.
She's going to go look for him.
Black Widow says she'll join her.
But just as that's happening in the Watcher starts
to narrate again from inside the room,
we get a bit of an end credit tag scene
with her getting sucked through
another multiverse portal to the Marvel 1602 universe
it's basically set up for the Marvel 1602 episode
like the last couple of episodes
It's basically Scarlet Witch using her chaos magic
to pull her across the multiverse.
she's with that universe's version of Nick Fury.
And when they reference saving their Queen,
that's supposed to be
a version of Cate Blanchett
playing another version of HeLa.
But it's Queen.
HeLa is meant to be kind of a meta Easter egg,
because in real life, Cate
Blanchett also played a version of Queen Elizabeth.
The first and Queen
Elizabeth's reign ended around 1602.
That was when King James
was beginning to take the throne.
but I think the idea is that in this version of what
if things have gone completely bonkers in that six,
you know, to reality with a bunch of different
characters getting sucked into this amalgam universe.
something is happening in this universe
that necessitates Scarlet Witch putting together
this multiverse team.
end, in the context of the episode,
Scarlet Witch is dressed in that old timey 1600s garb.
She's meant to be sort of a version of Merlin
in this universe.
Like one day Merlin.
fun fact Merlin,
Camelot, Excalibur, King Arthur.
All that stuff is king into the MCU.
that's where the ebony blade that the Black Knight Kit
Harington's character uses
originally came from it was created by Merlin
There's a bunch of Easter eggs in the episode, though.
So if you spotted anything that I didn't talk about
in the video, just write it below in the comments.
My full Episode six video will post tomorrow,
so be sure to enable alerts for my channel
so you don't miss that.
that's meant to be the
what if Corey reshape the world episode?
Click here for that, will update the link
as soon as I post that and click here for all my other
What if videos.
Thank you so much for watching.
And I'll see you guys in the next one!